think you know everything about the
Simpsons here's 27 Simpsons facts you
probably don't know
in 2013 the Simpsons were nominated for
an Academy Award for their short film
the longest day care Michael Jackson
co-wrote and co-produced do the BART man
Barbara Bush quoted that the Simpsons
was the dumbest thing she had ever seen
Marge Simpson wrote her letter in
response and actually got an apology
from the first lady
Marge's hair was originally so tall
because Matt Groening wanted to hide her
bunny ears you can see them in the
Simpsons arcade game The Simpsons movie
was banned in Burma because the colors
red and yellow are banned in films there
in 1997 you could win a fully furnished
Simpsons house the person who won took
the 75 thousand dollar prize instead if
you put all the clips of McBain together
there's a story arc God and Jesus are
the only two characters in Simpsons
history to have five fingers and the
opening credits Maggie used to ring up
8:47 63 because in 1989 that was the
estimated price of raising a baby for
one month Danny Elfman claims he wrote
The Simpsons theme on the drive home for
a meeting with Matt Groening Homer was
originally supposed to be revealed as
Krusty the Klown that's why they look
alike
Homer once had a theory that the
universe was shaped like a doughnut this
theory is said to have some validity
according to cosmologists the number
Bart uses to prank-call Moe's spells out
Smithers when he appeared in The
Simpsons Justin Timberlake didn't want
to say word so once they recorded him
saying at once they looped it and used
it over and over in the episode the
French voice actors that play Marge and
Homer got married in real life in the
Arabic version homers name is Omar after
Phil Hartman passed away all of his
characters were retired including Lionel
Hutz and Troy McClure they sometimes
show up in the background of scenes
according to their family tree The
Simpsons and mr. burns are distant
relatives Homer Marge Lisa Maggie and
patty are the names of Mack ratings real
family while Bart is an anagram for the
word brat talk-show host Conan O'Brien
was a writer on the show on Conan's
first day working on the show a bird
flew through the window killing itself
in the process his colleagues tried to
convince him it was an omen in French
episodes homers joke is translated to
Joe in Spanish it's ouch in Arabic
episodes homers beers replaced by soda
if an episode is too short
extend the couch gag in the opening of
the show Krusty the Klown is named after
rusty nails the clown who had a show in
Portland Oregon and finally Milhouse's
middle name is Mussolini